My goal was always to be in the UN.
I thought I was going to be a diplomat.
I threw that in the trash.
But the storytelling aspect of it all,
I think, does actually run deep.
And there is a real common denominator
between the things that I've done.
Yael Wissner Levy,
thank you so much for being on my show,
I'm so incredibly excited
to have you here.
I am too.
Thanks for having me, Michael.
I've been waiting
for this for a long time.
You're one of the most wanted
high tech entrepreneurs,
communications writers,
whatever you want to call it
in the world,
because the work
that you've been doing with,
well, yes, it just shows,
by me getting a hold of you,
and every person that I talk to
says how amazing you are.
Because the work that you've done
with Lemonade,
with being vice president
of communications there in the company,
that is revolutionizing the way that
content is being delivered
in the world of insurance.
And I'm now in the insurance space
with Hippo Insurance.
So, I get to appreciate
this art of communications
and content there, it's remarkable.
But I actually know you
back from your speech writing days.
And previously, as a news anchor.
So, you have a breadth of experience.
in the world of communications.
Yael, take me back to the good old days.
You're back with Channel 10 News
and then i24 News,
why journalism?
Why communications?
I will take you definitely back.
But I have to comment on those crazy,
crazy compliment you gave earlier.
I can't take any of the credit.
I work with an incredible team.
And I know Hippo also
has a really outstanding team.
But here at Lemonade,
I've been fortunate enough to work with
really the best entrepreneurs,
I think, on the planet.
And learning from them
and just kind of
being here for five years,
I'm actually celebrating
my five year anniversary
here at Lemonade.
It has been an unbelievable journey
on a personal level.
5 years. Wow.
Yeah, but also on a professional level,
really working side by side
with the top of the best.
Like really, really top talent.
But we'll get to that.
And yeah, as you mentioned,
I had an unorthodox way
of jumping into the tech scene.
But I like to say that if you look back
and try to connect the dots,
it's actually very clear.
It just wasn't clear at the time.
When I was in my 20's
and I was going through, as you said,
journalism to politics,
back to journalism, back to politics.
And it looks like
I was like hopping around.
Whereas I feel like
I was just diving deeper and deeper
into this world of storytelling.
And storytelling is actually,
the elements of it are pretty basic.
And you put it in journalism
or you put it in politics
or you put it in tech,
and the very kind of elements
and the fundamentals
of storytelling are the same.
And I started my storytelling experience,
if you will,
right after the army here in Israel.
Actually, even before.
Like I was,
I grew up in a home that was
very much of a storyteller's home,
books and stories.
And my mother is a teacher, as you know,
where part of the everyday life.
And I always like to write.
And kind of delve into that.
After the Army,
I worked in the US Congress
for a Democrat from New York.
And that's where I was exposed
for the first time to storytelling
kind of as a profession,
that was beyond just like the,
what I had known before that
as authors and so forth.
Suddenly, I saw all of these
members of Congress that would come
into the Senate or the House,
and they wouldn't say a word
without having their speechwriter
write it for them.
And it wasn't because
they were incompetent.
They were actually,
they're extremely
incompetent individuals.
And I was lucky enough to work with
Representative
Steve Israel from New York.
But they understood the power of the word
and the power of everything
that they were saying.
They had the opportunity
to change hearts and minds.
to get bills passed.
They had the opportunity
to get votes for their legislation.
But whatever it was,
I understood
that there was an opportunity here
and there was an opportunity
that I could not be missed.
And if you have that opportunity,
you have that time,
you have the attention of someone
in front of you,
how do you use it to optimize
what you're saying
so that people want to hear you
and activate or go out
and implement what you just said.
And that fascinated me.
That kind of very idea.
It's really human behavior
of how we internalize something
and we decide to go do something
because we read it or we saw it,
or we're actually looking at someone
as a role model
and trying to replicate or emulate them.
And Representative Israel,
Congressman Israel was really,
he saw this in me and I saw
and I was itching to write.
And it was the year
after the second Lebanese war,
and he was putting through a lot of
a legislation in Congress
around the end of the war.
And I asked to write
some of his speeches.
I also input a lot of
what he would be saying
on the floor of the House.
And that's where it kind of started.
From there, I went in to Haaretz.
And I was an editor on the website
for three years.
And then, went to Channel 10
here in Israel,
which is now Channel 13.
Right.
i24 News.
And then, i24 News.
Studied in London.
My goal was always to be in the UN.
I thought I was going to be a diplomat.
I threw that in the trash.
But the storytelling aspect of it all,
I think does actually run deep.
And there is a real common denominator
between the things that I've done.
So, if I can even say anything
that I learned from that is,
everything will make sense in the end.
If you follow your passion
and continue doing things that you like,
you don't need to
create your resume in advance.
You actually,
you look back and you'll say,
wow, that's actually
really does make sense.
Yael, the very first thing
that you said was,
storytelling, it's pretty basic
in its roots.
But I have to tell you,
I took a class very recently at Stanford
with David Demarest.
He was a senior staff
for the White House,
for George Bush Senior.
And we had dinner a few times.
And the stories that he told me
about the responsibility,
he wrote most of the speeches
for George Bush the senior.
And the responsibility and the burden
of being the storyteller
with the nuances,
and you wrote speeches
for heads of state, presidents,
CEOs, right?
And so, it's not just telling,
taking the content
and putting it in the nice way,
but it's actually the art of delivering
it and convincing others in your message.
And I can only imagine
the responsibility and the anxiousness
of watching them deliver the speech
and seeing the reactions.
Because we can see,
especially in 2020,
with the elections on all sides,
how every speech,
every debate is so fundamentally crucial
to the position of the candidates,
that I can only imagine
the skills that you have to build.
And what's remarkable,
I think about your journey,
that I'm getting a lot
of inspiration from is,
I see a trend today
that people are moving
very, very quickly between domains
as if it's like a check box.
And while you've moved quite a bit
from different domains,
you've really dug deep into them.
You've spent
five to seven years
in editing and journalism,
and then in speech writing,
and now in the high tech.
Five years spending in
in a hypergrowth startup,
that's incredible.
So, while you did change,
you really dug deep
into all of those subjects.
Do you feel that way?
Yes. And I think I do in retrospect.
I don't claim to have
known all of this ahead of time.
I didn't go out and say,
I'm going to spend five years here.
I mean, had you asked me
six years ago if I thought I'd be working
in an insurance company,
I would have thought
you were absolutely crazy.
That wasn't on my grand scheme of things.
But I can say that
one thing I have learned,
and this is only in retrospect,
so everything,
we're all so smart in retrospect,
is that the focus and kind of,
when you kind of focus
on one or two skills
that you want to hone on
and understand
and get really good at,
there's only focus.
You can't spread yourself too thin.
You have to know
what you're good at
and what you want to get better at.
And I'm a true believer
in getting better at stuff
that you're not great at.
But I also think that
when you focus on something
and you don't try to win it all,
you get to interesting results.
So, what are you really good at?
What is your focus?
So, I think, I'm trying to understand
the flexibility
and the dynamics of storytelling
to its core.
As I said, when I was just starting out,
I was absolutely sure
I was going to be a journalist forever.
And then that kind of turned into,
well, journalism is great,
and I think I can give a lot
and learn a lot,
but I don't think it's actually
going to change policy.
And then, I wanted very much to go into
the Foreign Service and be a diplomat.
And I went to school in London
thinking that that would be
my next step before the UN
or something like that.
And I think, in London,
my understanding there was,
sure you can go into the foreign service,
but actually, as you said,
the person really helping
some of the leaders
formulate their policy
are these ghostwriters or speechwriters
or whatever you like to call them.
And so, that fascinated me.
I said it's not only about the words,
it's about who you're working with.
And I was fortunate enough
to work with really top leaders
here in Israel,
writing their speeches in English.
And then that kind of relationship also
really fascinated me, because I said,
wow, if you take that relationship,
you put it to business,
to public companies,
and you work with CEOs
of a public company
and formulating their message,
how are they going to speak
when they have earnings calls
and stuff like that.
That really fascinated me as well.
And I was fortunate to work with
the CEO of Teva Pharmaceuticals
for a while.
And I started adding on clients
in business,
not only in politics,
and understanding that
in terms of the storytelling,
if I go back to what I started with,
this is fascinating.
This is something that
you keep on learning
and learning and learning.
And if I can focus on that
and get better
and kind of expand my knowledge
in the storytelling realm
by working with different leaders,
I really will expand
my knowledge base in general.
And then, it was pretty clear to me
after a few years doing that,
that technology and Silicon Valley
was where maybe policy
was even trumping a lot
of the things that are
in government and no pun intended.
That didn't sound very good.
But I did kind of feel like
I wanted to join something
that was bigger than
what I could do by myself.
Wait, Yael, were going to dive into this.
But I have to ask you before that.
Because I needed you to take us
into the mind of the storyteller
for a second, because,
you know, the majority of the people
listening to this, including myself,
are young, scrappy,
hungry entrepreneurs that are,
we tell ourselves stories
and we think of the world,
and we keep trying to reinvent things
that are happening around us.
Yet I'd love to learn
a little bit from you.
When you approach a story,
whether it's helping write a speech
for a president or for a CEO,
or for Lemonade,
what are some of the thought process
that goes into building this narrative
that at the end, others want to follow?
And I'm genuinely asking this
because I'm curious to
what constitutes a good story,
a good narrative?
So, I think one of the first things
that you have to think about
when you're writing anything,
and it's who you're writing for.
Who are the audience
and what do you want them to feel,
what do you want them
to take away from it.
Because everyone has,
especially in [--],
like zero attention span.
Right.
People are on the go.
They're getting their information
in 10 different ways
that you didn't even optimize for.
So, when you're trying to write something
you really need to narrow down.
It goes back to the focus.
Focus on who exactly
you want to be reading this,
and what they want to be feeling
or what you want them to be feeling.
And when you have that in mind,
you can kind of create that story
in a way that makes sense,
not for you.
A lot of times we're writing
and we think this is my story.
Sure, it may be your story,
but if you want people to go
and execute on that story,
or buy your product,
or believe in you and vote for you,
or whatever it is
that you want them to do,
you really have to think about them
and what they're feeling.
And kind of create that story
for them and not for you.
And I think, that's a lot,
it's kind of counterintuitive.
Because you open up your Google Docs
and you start typing
and you feel like you're
sharing who you are.
But it's actually not really about you.
It's about your any customer.
Whether that be constituents
and or your customer
or your parents or whatever it is.
Who is this audience.
And then the second thing
that I would say is that,
because we have such a short
attention span,
you need content,
you need stories or data points
or whatever it is
that you're constructing
that sticks.
Sticky content, they call it.
And it's something that
people will walk away,
if they can remember one thing
from what you just wrote
or what you just said,
or the infographic that you made,
what will that be?
And sometimes you need to shock them.
Sometimes it needs to be something
that is actually inspiring
and not just fluffy content,
which a lot of people like:
Oh, I read a nice quote somewhere,
let me put it in.
But nobody really remembers it.
Like, what is a sticky part
of your content
that you're going to be
leaving the audience with?
I guess, that would be mine to [--].
So, how do you know that?
So, when I'm sitting down
and I'm preparing a talk,
or I'm preparing a letter,
how do I know
if something is going to stick?
Do you test it out before?
Do you get feedback from others?
And how do you run
all those experiments?
Because that sounds complicated.
It is.
It's a lot of trial and error.
And it's a lot
of getting to know your audience.
So, sometimes you'll write something
and it will fall flat.
So, sometimes people will like that.
They'll say, "Okay, I wrote something."
People read it,
but it didn't do anything.
And sometimes that's like comforting
because okay, it didn't move the needle,
but at least it didn't get anyone angry.
On the other hand, if you take more risks
and you go out on a limb and you say,
"I'm not going to speak to everyone."
"I'm going to speak to
2% of my audience.
Because I know that those 2%
are the most engaged
and they will follow me
and they'll come after me
if I ask them to.
You see that a lot in politics.
It's not only--
I was just about to say,
I mean, we're watching it unfold live
to these different tactics. Right.
And so, you can't win everyone.
And you can't win
the hearts and minds of everyone.
But if you go when you say something
that will make someone's ears perk up
and another person's another person's,
you're probably going to get
a more engaged audience,
than if you say kind of the clichés
that everyone's used to.
And so, that's it.
You have to be a risk taker.
It's a lot a lot of risk.
And be prepared to kind of own
what you're saying.
So, when you sit down
and listen to a speech,
when you watch the news
or when you're listening
to somebody talk,
do you cringe sometimes?
Like do you have like,
wheels in motion saying like:
oh, this is the tactic
that they're using,
they're alluding to something bigger.,
they're trying to get me
to feel these emotions.
Do you have that process?
Yeah. Sometimes.
I try to take it off
because you don't want
to become too cynical.
You want to believe
that there is you know,
the cynicism will at the end
really make us
not optimistic to be.
So. I want to keep the hope alive.
I want to think that,
that there are people
that are speaking genuinely
and they're not trying to
artificially implant
all kinds of speaking tactics
and rhetoric and stuff like that.
And I do believe
that there are people out there
that are speaking from their,
their heart and their brain
and not trying to rouse up the crowds.
But, yes. You can't ignore it.
Once you see it,
it's like you can't unsee it.
I love it.
Yael,
so Vice President of communications
at Lemonade, hypergrowth startup.
You're joining very
from the early days.
And that's a fascinating thing.
Because you're coming in
from the political world
right into high tech.
What is that experience like
and what
was the journey like
reinventing the messaging
behind insurance?
So, as I said from the start,
I really am privileged
to be able to work
with two of the finest entrepreneurs
that I can think of today.
Daniel Schreiber and Shai Wininger.
They were tech veterans.
And they had been around,
been around the tech scene, so to speak.
And when they stopped at insurance,
they found an opportunity that really was
this huge opportunity
because it was so unchanged.
We have gone through decades,
if not centuries of
stagnation.
It was so unloved when they came.
And when I heard about insurance
for the first time through Lemonade,
I said, that sounds like, I don't know,
it can't be something compelling.
But that actually,
the fact that it was unchanged
and unloved was
a huge market opportunity
and a huge storytelling opportunity.
Because suddenly,
you can change the perception
of something that is really
such a fundamental part of society.
Right?
And when something goes wrong,
you want to make sure
that you have something to cover you.
And why did it lose its way?
What happened to that story of insurance
that started really
as communities coming together
and really lost its way
through the kind of evolution of society?
Kind of really ignored
every other revolution
that went through.
Insurance stayed the same.
And I think, that part of the story
of taking on an industry
that was so vast
but also so unloved,
is like a storyteller's dream.
It's an entrepreneur dream.
It's a product dream.
You can see it through any lens
that you like,
but really,
understanding the opportunity here,
both to work with Daniel Shai
and the rest of the team,
and also understanding the opportunity
at hand for the world,
a Lemonade is also a big corporation,
so understanding that we're
a for profit business,
but we have like social good
embedded in our business model
was something that
I want it to be part of that story.
I wanted to tell that story.
And as I said,
joining something that is bigger
than the sum of yourself
is it's really gratifying in the end
if it works.
And if even if it doesn't work,
it's great.
And all of a sudden, it's almost like
the ultimate challenge for a storyteller.
Because you're literally
trying to change the perception
of what it means to be insurance.
Because just like yourself,
I think the majority of the people,
they think of insurance until today
and they think of like:
okay, this is the enemy,
they're trying to take my money,
and maybe if I have an accident,
I can finally get the money back
from them. Right?
It's almost like a win
in front of your insurance company.
All of a sudden,
here you're trying to work on a startup
that is trying to create
a social contract with insurance.
What was the biggest challenge there
with sort of
trying to reinvent that messaging?
So, it's everything that you said.
Like, how do we make
insurance interesting
for people that never really,
either life insurance,
or in our case especially,
people that never had insurance before.
A lot of our customers
are first time insurance buyers.
Meaning, they never, ever had insurance.
What will make them
want to come to Lemonade?
And we've talk about Lemonade
in general, an insurance.
I think, Hippo, does also.
Similar messaging is understanding that
insurance can be lovable.
It can be spoken about in a way
that nobody ever dared
to speak about it before.
And when we launched in New York
in September 2016,
we started seeing people
tweet about their Lemonade experience
being delightful and amused.
And is it weird that I
love my insurance company?
And it started
ringing also back to us saying,
you know, we're on to something.
And if we make an experience
that is absolutely delightful
from start to finish,
that is seamless and fun
and brings smiles to people's faces,
and they can choose a charity
that they like to support,
then we're really kind of changing
the entire fundamentals of insurance.
Not just the financials,
but really how people interact with it.
And that's kind of the ultimate story.
And obviously, I think from the start
and I've been following the journey
for a long time,
there's so many different facets
that you've employed
in order to change that narrative.
Starting from the transparency
of being fully transparent from day zero.
And when you think of insurance,
you think of this like big monster
that's like getting all the cash.
And all of a sudden,
you're being transparent
about the financials
and about the intentions.
And I think that
I gained a lot of inspiration.
And I'm delighted to be now
with a self-funded hippo,
and seeing also
how the different companies,
somehow all of them are Israelis,
but also next to insurance,
they're coming in and all of a sudden,
such a big field
is changing so dramatically.
And at the end,
it's for the benefit of a lot of people.
It's for the benefit
of millions of people.
But unfortunately,
I can't believe 20 minutes are almost up.
I have about a hundred
different questions
that I wanted to ask here.
Yale, I want to thank you so much
for being on the show.
I really appreciate it.
Back from when
you very generously donated
your time to come
to one of my debate programs
or debate public school
to teach us about storytelling.
And that was
one of the most inspiring sessions
that we had and I've been,
I was in that club for about five years.
So, thank you,
going all the way back there.
And before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Oh, you ask tough questions.
The hardest one.
Yeah, it is.
I don't want to self described.
But I can tell you the three things
that I kind of really admire
and I hope that I use in my,
when I'm with my teams.
And they know this.
And so I'm happy to kind of
spread it around.
But the three things that I really admire
in a person and a leader are
resilience,
integrity,
and compassion.
And I think that the,
the three of them together
really kind of
touch upon different aspects
of leadership,
but also of human behavior
that is crucial.
Especially in 2020.
Yael, toda raba.
Thank you so much.
I can't wait to share
this with the world.
And best of luck
with everything that you're doing.
Thank you.